joining us right now on the Honda inside
a reporter's a man who hopefully I know
he speaks fluent Jerry Jones
so let's decide for the comments Tim
Calais Shaw from the Dallas Morning News
and also from around the horn back here
in the Rich Eisen show how are you Tim
I'm good it's hard to speak fluent Jerry
I've been trying for 30 years but it's a
difficult language so interpret his
comments postgame for us please these
weren't that difficult I mean it's funny
that a four-point loss to the Patriots
is where he sounds most damaging towards
Jason's future chances not a loss of the
Jets not a loss at home to the Packers
where Aaron Rodgers didn't have any
receivers but this game but but I mean I
think he it was a culmination and the
the plays you just talked about the Toni
Pollard one on the kickoff is the one
that I think frustrates him and that's
really the one that's about coaching
because you can debate the fourth and
seven decision I I didn't think that was
that terrible given that you've just
gone incomplete on second and seven and
third and seven but but I understand you
know you're down there and I understand
the argument excuse me argument for
getting the touchdown but Belichick
watches his guy Matt Patricia play he
wants us to Detroit tape from last week
in Detroit with vastly inferior players
but the same approach as the Patriots
and he sees Pollard dropping and kickoff
at the 10 not really good at handling
that that's indoors in Detroit so
they're gonna try to mess with him in
the weather and the Cowboys are
completely unprepared for it and I think
that's what that's what Jones was
talking about is special teams is
coaching and and one team was fully
coached and prepared and the other one
with their hoping to get away well I
think maybe and again you're right I
mean again this defense is maybe one of
the best defenses we've ever seen that's
a fact and the place where they're
playing is one of the toughest rote
venues to win in that maybe we've ever
seen this is now 20 straight wins for
the Patriots in Gillette including
playoffs but this is the litmus test
right this is the litmus test of
of a team that will have to be somewhat
reconfigured in the hole there is more
pie there is less pie front when dak
does eventually get either franchise
tagged or sign long term the window is
closing with five more regular-season
games and maybe he just saw right there
in person in front of him that a game
that was winnable when it all came down
to it was not because of decision-making
and preparedness Tim yeah I think that
all goes into it I just think they
looked that way on a regular basis Jason
Garrett was asked today this morning I
guess about does he talk to anybody
about winning probabilities and used
those fats and he said no we don't do
that in the game well you probably read
that sorry about John Harbaugh has a 25
year old win probability experts sitting
in the in the press box next to the
offensive coordinator telling him on
those downs what works and what the
percentages are and and but that's so
not Garrett to do things like that he he
definitely wants to be an old school
football coach coming from his dad who
was a scout and he doesn't want to I've
written before about the Princeton side
of his personality is like Spock and he
wants to shove that aside and just be a
football guy and and doesn't want to
hear about analytics
and doesn't want to hear about numbers
and probability and and sometimes those
things teach you a lot in the middle of
a game and cowboys have have no clue
about all that so what do you think
Jerry's going to do Tim I don't think
anything immediate I know there's people
thinking like they thought a couple
weeks ago oh they lose to Buffalo and
he's gonna do it Friday and I don't
think there's anybody natural to promote
I don't think the shine on Christmas
card is that bright right now so I mean
I think he I think it's always going to
come down to the plows look you know the
Cowboys might go eight and eight and win
the division
you saw the Eagles yesterday if they go
nine and seven they're almost certainly
going to win the division and get a home
playoff game but then they got to then
they got to beat San Francisco or
Seattle probably at home and then they
got to go win on the road to get to that
elusive NFC championship
it's hard to see that happening so I
think we will have a coaching change
well I mean yeah I again Tim I was
talking about at the top of the show I
was in the Superdome and we had Jerry
Jones on the set on NFL Network on our
pregame show when Wade was on the
hottest of hot seats and he just did not
want to fire him he just wanted nothing
to do with firing a guy we liked where
he believed well this team was the team
that he needed and they beat the Saints
they beat the Saints in a Superdome and
the Saints hadn't lost a game at all
that year and I just see him that that's
the guy that clearly didn't want to make
a change in the middle of the season
when he eventually did the very next one
all that said I don't see him making one
midseason but I do see that even you
know short of as you pointed out the
elusive NFC Championship game a change
is coming where do you think he looks is
Lincoln Riley is an obvious name that's
thrown out there is the obvious the most
likely in your mind I think it is
Lincoln Riley wants to do it we had him
on it I'm sure you and everybody else
has talked to him and he always says the
same thing I'm not interested the NFL
right now at some point he's going to
run out of Heisman type quarterbacks to
transfer in Oklahoma and they want to do
you know something else I think that
would be the first choice and even with
that I mean we don't know you know a
college coach is really good at coaching
quarterbacks I mean that probably makes
sense given as you got dak Prescott but
but they might have a decent some decent
voices around dak right now anyway so I
always think a guy in the NFL who's done
it up there makes more sense now I don't
I don't know who that is at this point I
you know at what point is this Jim
Harbaugh fall out of Michigan and come
back to the NFL I'm not sure it's just I
think Lincoln's the first choice and
then after that it can be anywhere from
any coordinator you want a name to Jason
Witten Jason Witten really I think I
think that's always a possibility if
Jerry truly believes all the players are
in place some of these assistants maybe
not
the special teams coach today some of
these assistants are pretty good but a
different voice you know in a more fiery
personality is what this team needs I
could see him doing that I don't think
it's smartest thing in the world but I
know a lot of people think it could
happen Wow Tim khalasar the Dallas
Morning News here on the Rich Eisen show
and it is remarkable how doc has played
this year Tim I mean he really has
shined I know yesterday was a tough one
but again New England has made every
quarterback look pedestrian not named
Lamar Jackson this year the weather was
dreadful Amari Cooper was erased by
Stephon Gilmore and all of that just the
way he's performed without a long-term
contract why is he not signed can you
walk me through why he has not been
signed to a long-term contract I think
he just made the ultimate you know roll
of the dice on himself thinking all
these people like me who said well he
really shouldn't get as much as Carson
Wentz maybe close to it he shouldn't get
as much as Jared Goff maybe close to it
all of us have been at the moment proven
wrong right now he's playing a hell of a
lot better than either one of those and
the notion of something averaging 30
million a year seems long gone and it's
going to be you know it's gonna be
Russell Russell Wilson's numbers or or
more exact just I mean he certainly got
lots of confidence and he has lots of
confidence in the team and from his
standpoint there was a one loss record
aside he has won that battle he's going
to get an enormous deal and as you said
earlier at some point they can't just
pay everybody a pre you know they went
in game Jaylon Smith more than they
needed to game DeMarcus plenty probably
gave Zeke more than they should have and
now they're gonna pay dak at that level
yeah they're never gonna be able to pay
a secondary because that's where they're
not spending money and and that's
hurting him son but he rolled the dice
and he is coming up a big winner so
finish this sentence for me I very
rarely ask the questions this way but I
think it's the best way to
answer it wrap up our Honda inside a
rapport with you Tim Cal show Dallas
Morning News as well as around the horn
finish this sentence for me the Dallas
Cowboys are six and five because Dallas
Cowboys are six and five because they
never surprise their opponents and they
they they play to their own level and
they don't the when they play good teams
this is a long word Eason so we've
already got several cards I'm sorry it's
okay when they play good teams they they
just go out and expect let's go practice
hard and play hard and not do anything
with real imagination and see if we can
beat him and yesterday I thought was a
prime example of that well I mean I
thought tell her Moore was supposed to
fix all that Tim Wright Miami and
Washington in New York did you see those
I did see that he was brilliant and then
and I know our conversation began with
you saying that you didn't take that
much issue with kicking the field goal
to make it a four-point game as opposed
to trying to tie the game on the spot
with their best field position of the
day on fourth and seven and you said
they had just gone incomplete two
straight times the reason why they were
in second and seven to begin with was I
could not believe they ran the option to
him I could not believe did they think
that they were gonna try and just shock
the Patriots or trick them you know as
opposed to just let's take Zeke and hand
the ball to him twice and see how close
we can get to the goal line for two
shots from say the the the six or five
yard line I don't understand it that's
what I'm saying
I mean minority and saying I didn't mind
that I think bustard wanted to do and
you heard Troy doing it yeah saying they
should go out for the touchdown and he's
got an opportunity but I would just hit
the play calling that led up to fourth
and seven that wasn't all world either
Tim thanks for the time we'll chat with
you down the road and greatly appreciate
it you got it at Tim Callie Shaw you can
follow them on Twitter for more of the
Rich Eisen show
tuned to audience channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app